[Music]
good evening and welcome my name is
Philip Khoury I'm the Dean of the School
of Humanities Arts and Social Sciences
here at MIT and I'm a professor of
history it's a privilege to introduce
this event which is titled America at
war a conversation with Helen Thomas our
sponsor is the communications forum at
MIT and I've been asked just to make one
brief announcement before we proceed and
that is this Wednesday at 5:00 p.m. in
this room in Bartos theater there will
be the third Communications Forum forum
the third fora if you like okay
on copyright and the two featured
speakers are Jonathan Zittrain at
Harvard and Siva Vaidhyanathan
at NYU and we urge you to come out for
this I gather it's been a very
successful couple of forums so far now
for more than four decades with pen and
paper in hand Helen Thomas has occupied
a front row seat in a theater where the
principal cast and the plot change every
four years or occasionally every eight
as a young writer she began covering a
newly elected president in November 1960
and then marked the transition from his
administration to the subsequent one
after his assassination
she has monitored presidential political
and military policies relating to
conflicts from Vietnam to the former
Soviet Union to Israel to the Falklands
to Libya and to Iraq she has written
about political scandals that have
involved wiretapping arms sales to Rouge
militants and love affairs with interns
she sits now
yeah I knew that would go down well Alex
okay she sits now pen still at the ready
offering commentary on measures mean
taking to stimulate our languishing
economy on policies that bear on our
role in Iraq and on the dozens of issues
that will emerge as the dominos tumble
after tomorrow's midterm elections
indeed as a member of the White House
press corps since 1960 Helen Thomas has
been reporting important national and
international stories in which nine US
presidents have played the lead she is a
legend in her own time which means she
is someone who refuses to live off her
many laurels by remaining as active and
as engaged as ever with her profession
of journalism on behalf of all of us
Helen I'm honoured to welcome you to MIT
I know this is your first visit and I
will confess that I knew her as a little
boy she wasn't much older than me then
so it's a wonderful reunion for me as a
longtime
eyewitness to history Helens
perspectives on politics and the state
of the Free Press are even more relevant
and valuable today and they will be
tomorrow
certainly as reporters and as
participants in public debates about
democracy about civil liberties about
foreign policy Helen Thomas and her
colleagues in the media serve an
important role in helping us to
understand what's happening on the
political stage to explore alternative
points of view and to decide what we as
participants in a democratic society
should do ought to do such an important
role doesn't come without scrutiny
however as we have come to question the
press as much if not more than the
players it covers what responsibility
accountability do the media have to the
citizens they serve
what is the media's responsibility to
the individuals organizations and
institutions
it covers Helen will address these
questions in relation to our current
situation in Iraq spotlighting the role
of the free press to both question and
to endorse and she'll explain how the
two have become either too entwined at
times
spin becomes news or entirely polarized
that papers too liberal or that ones too
conservative following Helens remarks we
will turn to our two respondents Charles
Stewart on my far right always on my far
right and David Thorburn David very
kindly has agreed to step forward on
very short notice to replace Henry
Jenkins who has been called away quite
suddenly and regrets that he cannot be
here has a personal issue that he had to
deal with out of town Charles Stewart is
professor of political science at MIT an
associate dean of our school he also
happens to be one of this country's
leading scholars of American politics
and behavior he'll offer a response
emerging from his extensive research on
the US Congress
David is professor of literature at MIT
and he's of course a director of the
communications forum and has been for a
good long while now our sponsor today
David is a media studies expert and is
one of the pioneers of television
studies in the United States and I want
to add that both David Thorburn and
Charles Stewart hold the highest honor
we have in the teaching world at MIT
both our faculty McVicker faculty
fellows there is no higher honor in my
opinion at this institution we're ready
to begin we're going to begin with our
featured speaker Helen Thomas welcome
Helen
[Applause]
well it's always hard to hear your
obituary but I have never had it done
more intellectually and as for the
questions I'm gonna leave that to the
experts good afternoon
or is it evening I'm very honored to be
here but I must admit when I told my
friends that I was going to MIT they
said why you can't add two and two and
there you'll be with all those nobels
and future Einsteins but I did come on
the eep eve of the midterm elections and
I don't have any of those answers either
my crystal ball is murky short of
predictions but long on hopes that the
Democrats will keep control of the
Senate it is up for grabs
they have only one seat in the majority
now otherwise you can be sure it will be
bombs away I can say that now because I
write an opinion column when I worked
for UPI wire service I had to stick to
the facts and now I'm allowed to have an
opinion or give everyone free at last
and now I wake up in the morning and I
say to myself who do I hate today and
then that's the that's the way you write
a column when I first wrote my first
column the editor said where's the edge
said the what your opinion my what after
50 years of censoring myself anyway it's
fun well I never beat around the bush
excuse the pun I hate war besides I've
lived long enough to see so many of our
reviled enemies become our friends so
maybe there is a better way instead of
The Killing Fields I've never covered a
president before in all my years in
Washington who actually wanted to go to
war first resort not not the end of
diplomacy not the end
talk not the end of negotiations others
would go of course but in this case it's
the first resort iraq has been on
President Bush's radar since he came
into office and even before whenever it
seems that he may be easing up his
cordon of hawk and harlot hardline
advisors rein him in not that he is not
obsessed Saddam Hussein is his white
whale it's more than that he and his
cohorts are pursuing a policy that is
alien to all that we've ever stood for
since World War two at least in terms of
collective security containment peaceful
diplomacy peaceful negotiations the Bush
policy of pre-emptive war is immoral
historian Arthur Schlesinger historian
Arthur Schlesinger thank you put it well
he said that such a policy would
legitimatize Pearl Harbor but he has
given a green light President Bush has
given a had been given a green light
from Congress so it's once more into the
breach with none of the lessons learned
since Vietnam sure will win that war
bombed the Iraqis who are left bomb them
into a democracy no other country is
really with us on this Tony Blair is
apparently not speaking for the British
people on this one the Air Force has
been doing practice runs in southern
Iraq and do I dare to assume that it is
hoped that some Iraqi will be pool a
foolhardy enough to give Bush an excuse
for the war that he longs for where are
the peacemakers I thought we had to
retaliate in Afghanistan but perpetual
war war without end is hardly what
anyone would want to look forward to for
their children for their children
the grandchildren what a way to begin
the 21st century and we thought that we
were going to live happily ever after
when the Cold War ended I have to admit
the Bush i'ts have played the war card
well the economy prescription drugs
other domestic issues have been pushed
aside rightfully so because clearly they
have no answers but well beyond this
country if Bush actually gets a
Republican Senate and House start
drilling oil in Alaska
forget Enron and the corporate greed
give those hungry Wall Street investors
a cut in the Social Security benefits
well I say Cry the Beloved Country we
have arrived at a stage where there are
no ideals no inspiration no hope it's
not only a swing to the right it's a big
slide away from the values and
principles that have made this country
so great we have seen Americans too
willing to give up their freedom for
security bigbrother style darkness at
noon as well as Orwell it's odd for me
to quote Bob Baer the conservative
congressman bar Masari who said that the
real test of freedom is not during
periods of peace and prosperity but in
times of national crisis I must say I
was surprised that some great Ivy League
academic defenders of civil liberties
were so willing to jump over to the
other side when they felt that the
country was threatened and to be as
vengeful as anyone else who has never
asked why the Attorney General had ruled
that deportation cases should be closed
to the public and the press fed up the
Detroit Papers finally sued and won a
ruling for to be able to cover some of
these deportation
hearings and federal judge Damon Keith
said democracy dies behind closed doors
we are so willing to accept an
unprovoked war as the United States
builds up its forces in the Persian Gulf
where is the outrage preemptive war is
not us
I maintain at least it wasn't us in the
twentieth century but we are being led
to permanent perpetual war by a man who
did not choose to serve himself when he
was about to be drafted for Vietnam and
that goes for all of his Hawk advisors I
don't think that's a low blow it's the
truth it's not it's not lost on the
American people that President Bush is
giving a pass to diplomatic talks that
is to North Korea which admits it light
and has nuclear weapons in production or
and wants to produce them has a program
and we are going to bomb Iraq which may
have them someday does that make sense
to you of course or is the oil that Iraq
possesses anyone want to send their sons
or grandchildren to die for a grab and
rocks oil fields would we tolerate an
attack on our nation that way when are
the American people going to wake up in
the case of Afghanistan I felt that the
the retribution was swift and right the
question to question two questions to
dissent is not unpatriotic it is
patriotic to be a thinking people and
not to roll over as Congress did for
fear that they will not get reelected
without thinking of the consequences
we should be working for true arms
control all over the world
we should uphold the treaties that we
have made since World War two that are
being torn up day by day Comprehensive
Test Ban Treaty non-proliferation treaty
any ballistic missile treaty and so
forth all the others that we signed
since World War two
we have even forgotten that we need
friends and allies we forgot that at
least till nine 12 then the president
was never off the phone for three weeks
calling everyone in the world all the
leaders in the world lining him up :
Powell Secretary of State was a Lonesome
Dove but he likes his job and there's no
room in this administration for a
devil's advocate President Bush has had
only six news conferences in his two
years in office that's a long time
between drinks and that is playing it
safe but not consistent with true
democracy the presidential and he has
his last news conference was on July 8 a
lot has happened since then the
presidential news conference is the only
forum in our society where a president
can be questioned on a regular basis and
held accountable otherwise he can rule
and is ruling now by executive order
autocratically imperialistic Lee I
maintain that is not us and that not
democracy you cannot have a democracy
without a free press free to ask
questions it's indispensable in our
system well what a difference a day
makes what a difference a year makes
we've had to tighten security like never
before
now that we know that we are vulnerable
not protected by two oceans I know I
sound like the bearer of bad news
blame the messenger were used to that no
question our world has been shaken shed
maybe but I am confident that we shall
overcome as Franklin D Roosevelt put it
at the height of the Great Depression we
have nothing to fear but fear itself the
philosopher George Santayana said that
if we do not learn from our mistakes we
are doomed to repeat them in the future
it is ours to reason why not just to do
and die we have to wake up speak up play
a role in the decisions that affect all
mankind it's up to us to make our public
servants accountable we in the press are
the self-appointed self anointed
watchdogs of democracy we try to follow
the truth wherever it leads us as long
as I'm on my rant I think we also have
to protect our civil liberties Benjamin
Franklin said if we are willing to give
up our Liberty for temporary security we
are in danger of losing both I speak of
wiretapping indiscriminate random FBI
accessing email lists FBI listening in
on private lawyer client conversations
rounding up dark-skinned
immigrants who have no appeal nor due
process some 700 detainees at Guantanamo
Bay held in limbo unable to contact any
member of their family or a lawyer of
course they are prisoners of war
captured in Afghanistan denied rights
under international law and the Geneva
Accords that's not us the international
world is wondering what happened to
America's great heart and soul sabotage
the biological chemical weapons treaty
we we have opposed the the Criminal
Court and so forth we're going to put
nuclear weapons in our last sanctuary
the heavens Winston Churchill said the
democracy is the worst form of
government except for all the others
that have been invented and I like what
Adlai Stevenson said Stevenson said
democracy is great not just because the
majority prevails but because it's safe
to be in the minority it's also said
that the only way for evil to prevail is
for good people to do nothing I shall
never forget the Martin Luther King
march on Washington in 1963 when he made
his immortal speech I have a dream black
and white kids walking hand-in-hand
together but I also remember the rabbi
who had been spent many years in a
concentration camp in the Hitler regime
and he said that the greatest sin of all
in the Nazi era was silence the French
historian historian de Tocqueville spoke
of America in its infancy and visited
here he said America is great because it
is good when it ceases to be good it
will no longer be great to me great
presidents have great goals for mankind
I believe that they have the greatest
honor that can come to anyone and that
is the trust of the American people
I've always felt greatly privileged to
cover the White House and to have that
ringside seat to instant history history
in the making
I've seen presidents highs and lows
always aware that they are human beings
sometimes I thought I'd give you a
thumbnail sketch of the presidents I've
covered John F Kennedy most inspired of
them all anyone who would say we're
going to land men on the moon in a
decade was either reading science
fiction or obviously had that vision
thing he said there's a universe out
there that we must explore he was the
state
at the time of the Cuban Missile Crisis
he avoided a nuclear holocaust lyndon b
johnson x' great society helped the poor
the sick and the maimed he rammed
through congress in his first two years
in office on the Tailwind of the kennedy
assassination
medicare the civil rights act voting
rights for blacks for the first time in
the south when they didn't have to
recite the US constitution or pay a
poll-tax
to register to vote public housing
federal aid to education at all levels
from headstart through college you name
it
but of course vietnam was his day naman
like most presidents Johnson had a
stable of speech writers and once he
once asked for that a certain speech to
be prepared and when the speech fraud
writer brought him the first draft he
looked at it and he said Voltaire
Voltaire people I'm going to talk to
don't know who Bowl chair is grabbed a
pen scratches out bull chair and
scribbled in as my dear old daddy used
to say and when when he was pushing
civil rights a group of a southern
cronies he had been Senate Majority
Leader came to him and said Lyndon what
is this when you were in the Senate you
were a southerner and he said I'm
president now president of all the
people he knew every man's price on
Capitol Hill and he knew where all the
bodies were buried Richard Nixon
brilliant politician who always had two
roads to go and he always took the wrong
road he will be remembered for the
breakthrough trip to China in 1972
starting which began the normalization
of relations between the US and China
after a 20-year hiatus 20-year gap and
he will be remembered as the only
president in our history to be forced to
resign because of the abuse of
government power his dark side always
prevailed
Gerald Ford restored confidence in the
white house and in the country in the
aftermath of the Watergate scandal he
said the long nightmare is over Jimmy
Carter put human rights at the
centerpiece of his foreign policy he
also is the most respected past
president of recent times and hats off
that he won the Nobel Peace Prize
finally after being nominated ten times
Ronald Reagan moved the country to the
right there was a Reagan Revolution he
also abetted the end of the Cold War
with a tremendous arms buildup George
Bush 41 best known for the Persian Gulf
War victory but we couldn't read his
lips when it came to the economy Bill
Clinton tarnished the Oval Office with
his personal liaisons but he did bring
prosperity to the country balanced the
budget he worked for world peace in the
Balkans Ireland Middle East and when he
was getting ready to leave office of
course all the White House reporters
wanted to interview him and we all had
the pro forma questions will you write
your memoirs what will your legacy be
but I think I asked him one prophetic
question I said to a mr. president if
you could take one thing from the White
House that belongs to the American
people what would it be well I didn't
know he was gonna bring a u-haul he said
it would be the moon rock which was
brought back by Neil Armstrong first man
to land on the moon and he said that
whenever his staff were in high tension
at each other's throats he would tell
them to chill out and point to the moon
rock and note that it's 3.6 billion
years old and that's what we call
perspective George W Bush 43 a work in
progress he has raised more than 125
million for the Republican candidates
his coordinate of advisors as I've told
you are all hardliners he likes being
president no sweat
he asked for advice on one-page
presidency has always been on the job
training so we'll forgive him his
philosophy is simple black and white
good and evil dead or alive with us or
against us except when it comes to the
transgressions of the greedy corporate
world and then he says you really can't
reduce this problem to black and white I
went to Washington during World War two
determined to be a newspaper woman I
just gotten out of college and Liz
carpenter who also became a great she
became a great Texas newspaper woman and
later press secretary to Lady Bird
Johnson arrived at the same time she had
just graduated from the University of
Texas and we both went knocking on doors
at the national press building and Liz
was always on the plump side and she ran
out of money a couple days before I did
and she wired her brother please send me
$200 or I'm going to have to sell my
body and he wired back sell it by the
pound all the first ladies I covered all
the first ladies I covered rose to the
occasion they found out that they had
great power and they could wave a magic
wand in support of a good social cause
and many supported their Crusades long
after they left the White House and mrs.
Johnson's of course was known for her
national beautification program which
transformed this land we love and she
has created a wildflower center outside
of Austin and a teacher took a group of
her school children one day to the visit
the center and she held up a photograph
of Lady Bird Johnson and asked the kids
do you know who she is and one little
boy piped up that's mother nature of
course the White House is always under
scrutiny and somehow presidents seemed
to think they can have their privacy my
feeling is that they want their privacy
and that's the issue don't go into
public life I also think that
if you really want to go into public
life you should decide at the age of
five and live accordingly when I was
first assigned to cover president -
elect Jimmy Carter I thought of that
interview he had given to Playboy
magazine where he said he had lust in
his heart well little did I know that
presidential lust would come much later
instead I found myself covering a Sunday
school teacher and when I tried to cover
Carter's Bible class in Plains Georgia
my male colleagues were allowed in but I
was blocked by a big burly bouncer I
finally convinced him I was no lady I
was a reporter forgive us our press
passes well nope no president has ever
liked the press dating back to George
Washington I wasn't covering him but
Kennedy said I'm reading more and
enjoying it less what LBJ said is
unprintable Nixon looked up when we
walked into the Cabinet Room one day and
said it's only coincidental that we're
talking about pollution when the press
walks in President Ford said that of God
had created the world in six days he
could not have rested he would have had
to explain it to Helen Thomas Carter
always seemed to be saying Lord forgive
them for they know not what they do and
when President Reagan was told that the
Sandinistas the Marxist had fired on a
press helicopter at the Honduran border
he quipped there's some good in everyone
and when a friend asked President
Clinton why the press always went along
in the motorcade when he went jogging he
laughed and said they just want to see
if I drop dead that's true
George Bush used to invite my George
Bush one just invite my younger
colleagues to go jogging with him better
them than me I got invited to the
dedication of the horseshoe pit well al
al Neuharth the founder of USA Today
said that when he went to Cuba to
interview Fidel Castro a couple of years
ago he found that Castro was very clued
in about America happenings here and he
asked Castro what's the difference
between your country and mine and Castro
said I don't have to answer questions
from Helen Thomas well as we start the
21st century I think that we can look
back on the last century in deepest
gratitude to the millions who made the
ultimate sacrifice for us two world wars
Korea Vietnam at the same time we also
realize that we've made great strides in
the last century which have brought us
great credit in terms of civil rights
women's rights human rights not to
mention the high-tech advances robotics
and so forth we're going to Mars and so
forth and we know that our quest for
knowledge should never end I have many
memories than covering the White House
they've been times to laugh times to cry
and times to wonder I remember when
Kennedy said an off-the-cuff remark at a
news conference life is unfair and I
remember when we asked him what would
happen if on Air Force one we asked him
what would happen if the aircraft
crashed I know one thing he said your
name will be just a footnote and I
remember when we were invited to the LBJ
Ranch for dinner and Johnson asked Bill
Moyers who had been a Baptist minister
to say grace Moyer's bent his head began
to pray Johnson commanded Speak Up bill
I wasn't talking to you mr. president
lawyers replied and I remember when
Johnson was taken to Bethesda Naval
Hospital for gallbladder surgery the
psychiatric ward had been transformed
into a
restroom what happened to the patients
Johnson asked moyers we gave them all
press cards said lawyers and then there
was Mitch Costanza who said I don't mind
Carter being born again but did he have
to come back as himself and I remember
asking Billy Carter if he too had been
born again he said once is enough nanda
was my all-time favorite miss Lillian
Carter's mother who said sometimes when
I look at my children I wish I had
remained a virgin when Carter was
elected president
a reporter ran up to miss Lillian and
said aren't you proud of your son she
said which one I remember interviewing
her during the Carter campaign she was
still fuming over a Frenchwoman
correspondent who had been labored
Carter's campaign promised never to lie
she kept asking miss Lillian what he
really mean by that finally she said
Miss Lillian do you lie miss Lillian
said well I might tell a little white
lie well what do you mean by a little
white lie in total exasperation miss
Lillian said you remember when you came
through that door and I told you how
beautiful you looked well that's a
little white lie several years ago on
Christmas in the Christmas season the
Washington Post said the General Colin
Powell was going to become President
Clinton's Secretary of State well a
little premature he had that's what he
is now
and I was invited to a Christmas party
at Sam Donaldson's house Powell was
there in my usual shy way I marched up
to him and I said general are you going
to be the next Secretary of State to
which he turned to another guest and
said isn't there some war we can send
her to well before 9/11 he sent me a
note saying I'm still looking for that
war and I sent him back the Vietnam
slogan hell no I won't go and then there
was Henry Kissinger woman ran up to
Kissinger and said Oh dr. Kissinger
thank you for saving the world
he said you're welcome
and once once once once Kissinger teach
his own Secret Service agents that he
might be kidnapped base by terrorists
they told him don't worry we'll never
let them take you alive and I remember
going to Moscow with President Reagan
for a summit meeting with Mikhail
Gorbachev suddenly the evil empire was
no more in Reagan's eyes and he noted
that the Russians laughed and they cried
and they were human when we got back to
Washington I said to him mr. president
do you think if you had gone to Moscow
ten years ago 20 years ago you might
have found out the Russians laughed they
cried they're human they're not bears
who walked like men he said nope they've
changed Justice Brandeis said that if
the government becomes a lawbreaker it
breeds contempt for the law he also said
that a constant spotlight on public
officials lessens the possibility of
corruption Lincoln said let the people
know the facts and the country will be
safe I believe that Jefferson said
eternal vigilance is the price of
Liberty engraved in the mantle in the
State Dining Room it's a prayer by John
Adams which says blessings on this house
may only good and wise men live here we
all hope for that and I believe that
people can handle the truth
and they deserve no less and we should
keep an eye on presidents who have
life-and-death power over all humanity
today to keep our people informed
democracy alive thank you
thank you thank you very much Helen we
will now move on to David Thorburn has
you know we work together this is how it
is David is elected to speak first
in response thank you I will I won't
even attempt to be as as witty or as
charming as Helen Thomas but I would
like to begin by giving you an
examination a test it's a pop quiz among
her many allusions and references Helen
Thomas made reference to a poem by
Tennyson in her talk did anyone pick up
on it
what was it yes she said she spoke
briefly she said ours is not to reason
why and of course she was referring to a
very famous poem which is deeply
relevant to our discourse in some
respects and I thought I might begin by
mentioning it to you it's of course the
the the famous poem that Tennyson wrote
after the catastrophe of a brigade of
light cavalry being ordered by the in
the Crimean War being ordered to charge
in two incredibly overwhelming canons
checked it was it was a horrific
military blunder a mistake on a
monumental scale to send light cavalry
in into the face of those guns and there
was an elaborate investigation
afterwards and and and and and the great
national act of mourning commemoration
and and self-flagellation in england
after the event and it was partly caused
by the power of Tennyson's famous poem
and in the poem he describes some of the
power of the poem has to do with it's
astonishing rhythms but one of the lines
in the poem goes something like this
cannon to the right of them cannon to
the left of them volleyed and thundered
stormed at with shot and shell boldly
they rode and well into the valley of
death rode the six hundred six hundred
cavalry men rode into those cannon even
as they began it they knew that it was a
that they were riding to their deaths I
think a more sensible leader might have
actually disobeyed orders and sent his
back to away from the front but they
were they were they were too honorable
and too full of sort of that we have to
obey our obey our orders and some of the
lines in the poem talk someone had
blundered is one of the lines in the
poem and one of the reasons that it
strikes me as relevant to our present
situation it is in some sense disturbing
and eerie to me because one difference
between our contemporary situation and
the situation in the 19th century
I could imagine easily and I think Helen
Thomas's discourse implies a and an
equally horrific and maybe even more
shocking blunder if it's a preemptive
strike by American forces on tort on on
others but the but the difference of
course as all of you are thinking I'm
sure is that our forces would be high in
the air free of danger the civilian the
the civilian casualties are likely to be
horrific the cost even if it's a
horrific blunder the cost will be to the
enemy and the country responsible for
the higher will not is likely not to
feel it part of the danger of bush it
strikes me part of the danger of what
president bush's has been talking about
although perhaps less aggressively in
recent days then then at the beginning
of his of his discourse about
pre-emptive war part of the danger of it
is precisely that if we go down that
road we are much less likely immediately
to feel the consequences of such
behavior horrible as it is the of the
600 members of the Light Brigade who
charged into the mouth of fell something
over 400 of them were killed and a
shocking a shocking casualty rate but it
was a wake-up call to that to that
society and to those people in a way
such wake-up calls maybe less available
in in a high-tech environment in which
war is conducted by digital technology
and high-flying airplanes and so-called
smart bombs so it strikes me as a
irrelevant and disturbing imperfect
analogy I wanted to I also thought it
would it was worth saying what I take it
most of you were felt I think that Helen
Thomas
offered us a very powerful indictment of
the current behavior of the Bush
presidency from which I certainly have
no significant dissent I think that the
notion of pre-emptive war is as dubious
and as vulnerable as Helen Thomas
suggested I think her comments about the
implicit incoherence and inconsistency
of the Bush policies are especially
notable and worth recalling and also her
reminder to us of the extraordinary
danger to civil liberties in the country
that has already begun to build because
of the rhetoric of the administration
deserves I think underlining but her
most powerful but for me the most
powerful and disturbing aspect of our
discourse maybe it's that I don't expect
that much from the from the from the
collection of managers and and oil
company apologists who surround
President Bush the most shocking thing
to me in some ways that that Helen
Thomas dwelled on a bit mentioned a bit
and then I think we might want to talk
more about in our conversation has been
the astonishing soup penis of the
Congress the astonishing the absolutely
astonishing truly shocking cowardly
behavior of most Democrats it's it's
quite amazing that Helen Thomas said you
know in her in our talk today was 50
times more eloquent than almost any
Democratic politician has been in public
about the shocking inconsistency and
folly of this administration's behavior
our our democratic car is the Democratic
Congress so nervous about it's
ridiculous jobs that it is afraid to
speak the truth in a moment like this
that strikes me as almost more shocking
and more horrible because they know
better because they know at least Bush
presumably believes what he's doing
maybe perhaps believes what he's doing
in any case some of the some of the war
mongers in his in his administration
Richard Perle and and and the Secretary
of Defense surely believe what they're
doing contemptible as those beliefs may
be there are many Democratic politicians
who know perfectly well how shocking and
inconsistent and morally dubious as well
as politically impractical these plans
are
but they're silent about it and it
strikes me as in that sense of very very
depressing time for our for our for
supposedly for our democracy let me end
with a with a with a little reminiscence
of my own about the Vietnam era and in
that in this sense I have at least one
minorly optimistic thing to say to you
in response to the kinds of thoughts
that Helen Thomas's discourse generated
in me I was very active as a relatively
active in my in my graduate student days
and in my days in my early days as a
young professor in the anti-war movement
against the war in Vietnam and and one
of the most important things that I
recall about that time is seems to me to
lead to at least a partly optimistic
conclusion after all the negative things
that I've been saying and that Helen
Thomas has said and that is that in the
very early days of the anti-war movement
and in the United States during the
Vietnam era in the in the early 1960s in
1961 62 63 the year of Kennedy's
assassination when we began to send
advisors to Vietnam without that was
never in the beginning even any formal
declaration of our involvement there the
amount of anti-war discourse in the
larger population was relatively small
there was very you would never read an
op-ed piece in The New York Times
questioning the motives of the war and
it was as late as 1965 or 1966 that the
secretary of state of the United States
Dean Rusk said there is no significant
body of opinion in this country this is
almost a direct quotation I used it many
times in my anti-war talks in the 1960s
no significant body of opinion this
bastard said no significant body of
opinion in the United States as opposed
to the war in Vietnam by the time he
said that in 1965 many university
campuses were hotbeds of anti-war
activity but the truth is that none of
the anti-war activity in those in those
early in those in in those early stages
came from public sources either so we
didn't we weren't hearing from
congressmen we weren't hearing from
senators
in those in those early days but it is
still the case I think that that that
the present situation in the in our
present situation one of the what the
prime difference that I see between
those days and now is that even though
the politicians are keeping their mouths
shut and are behaving with I think
contemptible cowardice and self-interest
probably mistaken self-interest ordinary
people are speaking out there is more on
the op-ed pages there's more on the talk
shows and on radio there's more general
fear and opposition to any proposal to
invade Iraq bubbling in our society now
then was remotely the case as late as
1965 or even 1966 in the and that's I
think a positive my guess is my belief
is that if the Bush administration
really is so foolish as to pursue some
sort of a pre-emptive war the amount of
anti-war the explosion of anti-war
activity into the streets will be
surprising to everyone except those of
us who remember the Vietnam era and and
and and remember what what can happen
when when when an aroused citizenry
begins to instruct its government about
what constitutes reasonable behavior at
least that's what I hope will happen if
Bush is so foolish as to go down that
road
[Applause]
so this is um too difficult uh backs to
follow
not only have we heard two very
compelling views about about the state
of the world today but I teach a
freshman advising seminar those of you
most people here are probably familiar
know about these things and I'm teaching
about cooking doing a cooking class
actually this term and about an hour and
a half ago we were making and eating
wontons and I have a belly full of them
right about there and so I'm gonna be
looking down on my notes a little more
than I would like just to kind of get
over the wanton problem we shall call it
but all my notes I kind of a feeling
that the conversation would go this way
I want to say something that I think is
ultimately in the spirit of what both
Helen Thomas and David have said but
come at it a slightly different way and
actually suggests that in the politics
of going to war with Iraq perhaps going
to war with Iraq over the last couple of
months there's been both the supine
behavior but there's also been an
interesting debate and an interesting
dynamic and public opinion and I'm
curious about the degree to which this
this pattern might emerge going forward
and so let me kind of lay out my
argument a bit and to kind of see where
it goes and I'm going to start off
perhaps a bit maybe even overly
conventional into political science II
but then come back to what I hope is the
hopeful point here and so in any case I
mean going to war is a pretty awful
thing and miss Thomas mentioned in the
beginning that there were lessons of
Vietnam and and there's one lesson of
Vietnam that I think we all understand
hawks and doves and that is that a
nation shouldn't be dragged into war
without the public's approval another
lesson that was learned within
Washington at least and as less well
understood is that well the president
shouldn't go to war without Congress's
approval and that's certainly what we
witnessed and September was watching a
president try to get Congress's approval
of course these two things go together
the public that the president wants to
get the approval from is not of a it's
in it and this public can't ask
questions it can't
speak with one voice that's what
Congress is there for and so these two
things go together getting Congress's
approval in getting the giving the
public's approval go together and during
the months of September and October we
saw this dance between the President and
Congress over what precisely should Iraq
policy be and the interesting thing of
course is that you know this is a
society where secrets aren't easily kept
and that dance took place in public and
as a consequence of what was relatively
a narrow debate within Washington there
was nonetheless the development of quite
sophisticated public opinion that um I
would say and probably a little less
passionately but nonetheless agree with
what David just said and that is you
know the spirit of that and that is
moving forward there's been a ground
laid a groundwork laid that hasn't been
there in many other you know adventures
around the world and so here's sort of
the I guess the the hopeful scenario
Americans don't like to talk about
foreign policy we know that they hate it
on what they like to think about is
there is there a world they'd like to
think about the price of potato chips
and they'd like to think about whether
their kids have good schools and the
rest and this shows up in public opinion
all the time and in fact on the Pew
Center for the research and the people
in the press asked in October likely
voters a bunch of questions and they
actually asked them to two questions
that got a lot of attention one was what
is the the thing that you've been
talking about most in terms of national
politics and the thing they've been
talking about the most was Iraq in fact
along the long list that we all know of
issues that one could talk about in
September and October they were talking
about Iraq more than half more than
terrorism more than the economy nor more
than Enron more than anything else then
they were asked well what would you like
to talk about it wasn't Iraq not
surprisingly it was the economy it was
terrorism it was education and it was
the rest now a number of my friends my
Liberal Democratic friends have taken
this news as being really horrible and
as evidence actually that politics isn't
working in America and the evidence
is this that Americans really want to be
talking about the sorry stated the
economy and it's a pretty sorry state of
the economy and any other midterm
election we would expect the Republicans
to be getting hammered right now because
the poor state of the economy and we
would not be wondering right now whether
Republicans are going to whether the
Democrats could possibly pick up seats
in the Senate or the or the house we
would just be assuming it but things are
really really different right now
okay so Americans want to talk about the
economy with them even they've been led
to talk about Iraq well I think it's a
great thing they've been led to talk
about Iraq quite frankly and I think
it's a great thing that we have a press
that has figured out in Washington what
the important issue is so while it is a
sad thing my doing my liberal democratic
hat to think that we're coming into a
midterm in which the poor economic
performance cannot be an issue and in
which we cannot blast the incumbent
president for that nonetheless the press
was focused on rather the people were
focused on Iraq in September and October
and the reason they were focused on Iraq
was there was a drama going on a
Washington as bad a drama is that was
and that drama was over whether delay
and army and all the astronaut delay but
army and all those guys would come along
and support the president in the end
they did and in the process the public
developed a really kind of interesting
public opinion and it certainly isn't a
fully formed public opinion is going to
emerge even further so at the beginning
of September most Americans believed we
should go to war against Iraq we should
do it now and we should do it without
any of the world coming along with us by
the time the resolution was passed the
beginning of October roughly the same
number of people said we should go to
war with Iraq but most Americans said we
should go only when our allies are with
us only when the UN is with us and only
as a last resort they did not believe
that a month ago so somehow this is a
very interesting message got into that
craniums of most Americans who mostly
want to think about the prices and the
grocery stores and their kids education
they actually developed a pretty
sophisticated view on the situation in
Iraq so the responsibility of the press
is multifaceted in a time of war and I
think that a lot of times we focus on
issues
of secrecy of the denial civil liberties
in the rest but an important thing that
I think that we've meant that we've
witnessed over the last couple of months
is the press continuing to point out the
important thing and the important thing
right now is that as Helen Thomas was
pointing out me America used to not be a
nation of pre-emptive war now we might
be coming at a nation of pre-emptive war
and so I'll just conclude by saying the
hopeful thing and then asking the
question the hopeful thing again if you
haven't gotten the point is that a
dynamic has begun in the public
discourse that like it or not the public
is gonna be talking about the Middle
East and about issues of war and are
going to be dragged into developing a
sophisticated understanding of the issue
should we in fact go to war and I think
it's actually less likely then some
people think that we will go to war but
should we go to war we're prepared to
talk about it in ways that we weren't in
other in other cases and that's an
interesting thing so the question really
becomes is there's a number of ways for
me to go from here one is to assume as
with David that once the once once the
war should a war happen that naturally
there would be a revolt on college
campuses and naturally it will be will
be situated to resist mightily in my
view just having watched the last couple
of weeks for that to happen it would
require not only people in the street to
keep going but it also required the
press to keep the skeptical eye on a war
and on the one thing that hasn't been it
hasn't really been touched on so far and
I would love to hear what you have to
say and what other people have to say is
that should we go to war with Iraq has
the would the sophisticated view or more
sophisticated view of the policy that
we're seeing in the press and we're
seeing the public develop would that
more sophisticated view continue to be
pushed in the press among members of the
press corps or is there a tendency even
at that point for not only the public
but and not only the Congress but then
the press with a real shooting war to
throttle back a bit and so I'll just you
know conclude by saying that you know
agreeing that you know the
the guarantor of liberties in this
country is the press and Helen Thomas is
worse a day in her career our evidence
that without the press we would end up
going compel willy nilly into some
pretty frightening policies and I think
that the best thing that we can hope for
over the next couple of years is
continued descent and continued
sophisticated analysis as much as we can
get and as public as we can get so just
before we open up to the floor I thought
Helen I don't know MIT has certain
traditions but not lots of them but on
this occasion if you wish you may wish
to respond to David or to Charles or we
can just go straight to the floor it's
up to you well I would like to say that
I was I'm thrilled to hear both of you
because you've given me a lot of
thoughts and it's nice to have a strong
support supporter and you gave me hope
because if the president goes to war
tomorrow the ball game is over but if
it's allowed to ferment as you said and
I really believe that people will really
begin to think what's this all about
healthy and I honestly think that the
more we think about it the more we'll
realize how foolhardy it is except I
think that this president looking for
any excuse and will use any I mean if
we're ordering practice Robinson no-fly
zone we're hoping they'll shoot us right
I'm a didn't have a good pretext to go
to war he's got none so far it hasn't
been able to sell it and they are they
were very open about it Karl Rove last
January issued a memo to all the
Republican operatives around the country
maybe that's the wrong word leaders to
that don't forget we've got the war card
we're gonna play it and they have played
it and that's why it's on the agenda and
that's why it's in the conversation the
president has not made any
speech about the price of popcorn or
anything galaxies definitely stayed on
message with just war and he's really
psyched up the people and think that he
doesn't he has not been accountable as I
said before as I complained before every
day I asked I read flusher when is the
president ever going to have another
news conference when you don't have one
since last July and you're taking a
country into war and there's no other
way to make them accountable we don't
have a prime minister going before a
House of Commons or being questioned so
I'm hoping that people will begin to
think but I also think in terms of the
campus
you know the campuses were on fire and
George Bush was that Yale he didn't even
know there was a war going on this in
Vietnam but there also was the question
of the draft when young people on
campuses definitely felt more vulnerable
of course they became more interested in
the war and having to go to a war that
they didn't believe in and the whole
you're right about the lesson of Vietnam
which is that you cannot fight a war
unless people understand the reasons why
to die and certainly we saw the
evolution of Vietnam Washington Post New
York Times supported the Vietnam War in
the initial stages but gradually when it
came back to the point where we're we're
going to have to bomb him to the
stone-age to really win the wars and
they could fade into the night we didn't
even know there was an underground
channel in Saigon we were there 15 years
of the CIA and so forth so there was no
way they could win the war unless they
really did almost a total annihilation
and and American people got really fed
up by that time and they realized that
you know to destroy a village and
restore it and this is what you hear
about Iraq now which is so shocking oh
we're going to we're gonna wipe them out
and by god and then we're gonna build
you see on CNN it says life after the
war there is so much assumption here
that we're practically we've won the war
were in the war and
there's no full stop I wish there would
be to be more thinking but I think that
people that the question of
inevitability has sunk in now where
people think we've got no more say about
it Congress has given him the green
light and so forth well I think the
people do have a say and I do think that
this White House responds to polls at
least if some in some way if his polls
would continue to go down and he would
see that this was not valid you know
there is no reason
Iraq has not provoked us in any way for
11 years we've had satellites AWACS
overhead we know everything that moves
in Iraq on the surface we've had typed
economic sanctions where their children
have not been able to get medicine for
ordinary baby illnesses and we bombed
them and we bombed them every other
night in the no-fly zone but we don't
have reporters there we don't know where
they're going or anything else not that
I don't trust this government
and then you have the total secrecy they
tell you nothing I wa I think that the
truth doesn't hurt us in any way it's
not just Iraq why don't we know about
terrorism why don't we know the causes
they have done everything to sabotage
the the creation establishment of a
commission to look into the causes
how can you rectify a situation how can
you change it how can you make a
difference treat it whatever if you
don't know the reasons and they don't
want you to know the reasons it's not
just political because obviously other
administration's the Clinton
administration will be to blame too I
mean talk about missing the boat all
over the place and not connecting the
dots it wasn't just this administration
but I'm in a tender here which is known
for its intellect and the intellectual
ferment and thinking and there is nobody
in Washington in the higher echelon who
wants to think why there is only one
question on the table and that is why
why are we hated now why should we ever
be hated we've always been loved what
made us lose so much ground and so much
affection and respect in the world thank
you
okay I think we can now open up to our
audience and remember what Helen said
dissent is a good thing yes yeah we have
microphones patty it would be good to
identify yourself since there isn't a
record of this sure my name is Nils von
stud I'm from I'm a PhD student at the
Sloan School of Management here and I
was interested in hearing more about the
issue of press access to information
regarding Wars for example and how that
axis has evolved over your years of
covering the White House and
specifically heaven and how that trend
which seems to be towards less and less
axis how that can be changed if in any
way well I think that the media
overlords have really made down on the
job they should be complaining
protesting the fact does anybody know
anything that's going on do you know we
have a war in Afghanistan not really a
war I mean it's a Special Forces action
police action whatever we aren't
fighting an army navy or anything else
what are we really doing there we've had
no casualty figures or anything else
Rumsfeld struts and swashbuckle is every
day and refuses to answer the questions
act like everybody is some nincompoop
you know but he for even asking during
the Vietnam war correspondents could hop
on a helicopter and go to any front they
could go anywhere I mean that was a wide
open deal that sure they would attend
the five o'clock Follies that were given
by the Army Headquarters and so forth in
a hotel in Saigon but they also went to
the front and they saw they knew what
was happening and hence you got the
books and hence you got the dispatches
that really questioned what are we doing
there
you don't have that anymore I mean they
have really the word around and this is
strictly rumor what's at the Pentagon
they said never again will we allow a
war to be covered like that and they
drew up a master plan of how to contain
us and they did a good job in the
Persian Gulf War in terms of having
briefings at the at the Pentagon and in
Riyadh and they were very coordinated
and so forth but they wouldn't they
really limited the reporters who could
go to the front now I think that they're
really trying to control everything they
might allows they're allowing some
reporters on the aircraft carriers in
the silver but there is no real real
coverage of these Wars everything is
under their control
spin manipulation management yes in the
blue sure I think thank you very much my
name is Michael Haley I'm an alum and
I'm an instructor at a Harvard Medical
School
I wonder if Helen thank you first for a
for great insight that I think none of
us could get from from any other source
and along those lines one of the things
that I've seen in the last couple years
that I wonder if you could comment on is
really kind of a loss of principle in
how people conduct public affairs I mean
we when we were talking about war in
Serbia there are lots of people who were
saying there's no compelling interest
for Americans to fight this war and
those people are strangely silent now
when the question of interest happens to
cross party lines we saw that in the
elections when the people were
traditionally states rights had always
advocated states rights all of a sudden
wanted Florida to change their you know
how they were wanted to tell a Florida
how to do their elections and it seems
to me that that there there's evidence
of that happening that we see all the
time now and is that is is principal
something that we as maybe younger
people look back on and and say that's
something that happened
the past isn't true in ours that's
something that's always really been
going on and and we've just ideal eyes
what's happened in the past consistency
is the hobgoblin I mean the treatment of
Iraq versus North Korea to me it shows
you the difference for they're very
pragmatic they do what they can do and
they do what's what is within the realm
and they can knock off Iraq but they're
very difficult to go to the Pacific at
this time and so forth so I think this
question of principle has not entered in
here what is the principle are we
against dictatorships great or do we
think that nobody should have any bombs
but us great I mean but not not gonna
work you can't control all humanity that
way so you have to have a policy
yourself you have to represent something
yourself you have to work for arms
control and you can't tear up everything
and have people look to us as some sort
of Savior then why do we think that
people wouldn't follow preemption once
we make it stick if it's good for us
where is the principle one quick one
quick edition I mean I I think there's
we all have a kind of nostalgia for an
older time when there was greater moral
clarity my guess is that we've proud
that our institutions have probably been
always about as corrupt as they are and
about as good as they are that there's
probably very little case it would be
hard to make a case for a past time that
was more admirable but I but I do think
that one it's one strand of the
discourse that I think Charles clarified
for us in his comments is worth
emphasizing again and maybe ought to
become a fuller part of our discussion
which has to do with the failure of
particular institutions Charles's
suggestion in effect and I think he's
right about this is that without the
press we might be at war now I think
that's very likely there has been a
change in the in the in the tone of the
of the bush rhetoric is in the last
couple of weeks and that's surely partly
a consequence of the way the major media
and especially institutions like the New
York Times and The Washington Post in a
kind of relatively quiet way began to
publish op-ed pieces by dissenters who
were very distinct
like prime ministers of Europe or but or
or or or a very important older
Republicans who had served in Bush woman
and the effect of and that I think that
began to build up in an in a way that
that began to certainly had the
consequence of moderating the rhetoric
but the more interesting question to me
is if it's true that our that our press
has been something of us of a savior
here a very helpful institution it seems
to me the the alternative conclusion
would be forced to be drawn about
Congress because this election ought to
be about the war we are people the
Democrat people the Democrats ought to
be running against the bush policy but
when we cast our votes tomorrow we're no
match for not none of the politicians
who are at war standing for office now
are articulating a clear position on
this question and to me that means that
our political institutions are not
functioning they're not functioning at
the level that it's healthy society
requires I want to interject one point I
do not absolve the press I think we have
rolled over and played dead we have sent
the spin out we have not there hasn't
been any real decent other side of the
question
every Khong columnist colonist I should
say it's a in on the Washington Post
everyone but one or two has been for the
war pumping it up every day every day
demonizing not just Yasser Arafat who
became the demon and they were so
successful wipe him out he's nothing now
I mean Saddam Hussein every day I'm
holding no brief for a monster but I can
assure you that this is definitely a war
drum beat in the middle there yes yes
you
my name is Agee I'm kind of on the 9
year plan here I went here undergrad and
oh my grad student and Miss Thomas has
just anticipated part of one of my
questions and there's about 10 tumbling
in my mind so I may be a little
inarticulate but I was wondering
professor Stewart said that he thinks
that there's been a sophisticated
discourse in the press and I feel like
just the opposite is true and that
particularly in the traditional media
we're being sort of fed very simple
storylines that people can follow and
also the peace movement I think has been
very much downplayed and ignored and I
was wondering how you think since miss
Thomas it seems that you agreed to some
extent how you think this might change
if you think the pressures of
alternative media might do so or if the
press will in some way come to its
senses and learn to give facts and be
less frivolous Thanks well let me let me
try to try to stoke it a bit and and and
and and maybe as I understand the
question so the question I guess to
restate what I had stated and maybe we
could talk about it a bit if I say it
was sophisticated well gee um more
sophisticated than I imagined and so
just to kind of rehearse that I mean one
of the things I think we need to
remember is that if we were to try to
find a time in America's past in which
there was a really sophisticated
argument about whether to go and award
any given moment and full-blown dissent
about doing it it would be hard to find
now it wouldn't be that you couldn't
find it it's just that it would be
really really really hard to find and so
when I look for instance in the Gallup
poll or the pew poll there's various
polls and discover
that 36% of the public thinks that going
to war is as a bad idea now some people
think that's a smaller number but given
past history the fact that we may be
going down award road to war with 36
percent of the public saying is a bad
idea it's a new thing in American
history as such that's just for one
thing is that that's DIF unexpected and
where does that come from maybe it does
come from the alternate media my guess
is it's coming from whatever people can
glean from the mainstream media because
even though the alternate media has
grown still by and large Middle America
gets their news from the broadcast and
from and actually get most of their
political news from the newspapers so
that's just one thing that I mean
compared to what we in Cambridge a way
to Mighty Mite want its unsophisticated
an uninformed
and pretty supine but compared to
American history it's you know it's
maybe at least descent trying to break
out at the beginning so that's the first
thing and the second thing again when
you look inside those polls you see
folks being either schizophrenic or
nuanced you can kind of depend on how
you feel today how you characterize it
nonetheless yes we should go to war but
we should wait we should wait for these
people you know so that again I mean my
guess is that when opposition to the
Vietnam War first broke out I mean I was
I was a mere child at the time but
watching it on newspaper it appeared to
be pretty polarized some pretty bit
realloc and not a whole lot of well on
the one hand well on the other hand and
right now there's a fair amount of well
on one hand well on the other hand the
final thing I guess I'll say is sort of
an offensive Congress is which is what I
studied I guess that's my role here is
that you know I was listening to the
radio during the debate and the Senate
and I heard this speech and it was Bob
Graham from Florida and I'm just
listening to him talk and I he finished
and I thought gee Bob Graham of
Florida's gonna vote against the war how
weird well in fact he voted for the war
although he gave a speech against it
well well I took to be you know these
are all the reasons why this is a stupid
idea and you know if you're really gonna
do this these are the things you got to
convince us of and this is where you're
gonna cut it do and if you screw up it's
your fault
and that's interesting so you know so
this doesn't exactly kind of address
your point except to say I do think that
I do think that the messages out there
are more diverse than they would have
been 30 to 40 years ago and just as
government has learned lessons of
Vietnam I think the press and the public
learn lessons from Vietnam one of those
is just to be be skeptical and just keep
in mind there are strong pressures in
any country at any given point at this
moment to go along with the leaders
notice the history good point of
governments and their citizens and the
fact that we have a third of our
citizens saying this is not a good thing
is at least no glass half full without
revealing my age I would like to say
that before World War two there was a
real split in this country between the
interventionists and the non
interventionist Hitler was was on the
move and so forth but we had people like
Gerald L K Smith by the cogman and so
forth and the other side very very Pro
German and and the memory of memories of
World War one gassing and all of the
horrible Verdun and the terrible
terrible things that in that war I mean
the memory lived long into the 30s and
it wasn't I mean there was a real split
in this country in a real debate it went
on day after day was very strong and of
course FDR obviously thought that we
were going to have to get in at some
point in terms of giving lend-lease to
Britain and so for giving as much
support as he could to Churchill and the
inevitability but then Pearl Harbor of
course you know made the decision for
all of us and then we rallied everybody
rallied around the flag and had to and
realize that Hitler had to be stopped
so but there was real real debate
between the interventionists and the non
interventionist
let me take someone from the back and
then I'll come to the front next please
someone could give that person a
microphone my name
whoa hi there my name is Ellen frist I
used to be a staff person here at MIT
I've received a Master of Divinity from
Harvard and I work a lot with
non-violence I was a Peace Corps
volunteer in Morocco so I know a lot
about what's been happening with this
kind of Islam bashing Helen thank you
very much for all of your candidness and
I agree with you a hundred percent thank
you
and I do think that the Congress has
been very weak in standing up even the
constituents in this state who have
asked John Kerry that we don't want
there to be a yes vote for the war and
he voted yes anyway so there is an
alternative Democratic candidate that's
a write-in candidate her name is Randall
forsberg and her address is 950 Mass Ave
Cambridge and she is oh is a write-in
candidate for John Kerry for me having
lived and just coming back from the
Middle East I'm very concerned about
what can be the repercussions if we go
ahead and have a war with Iraq because
we will not we're not safe now but we
really won't be safe if we do go ahead
and walk into Iraq so I'd like to hear
anyone on the panel talk about what does
that say around our ethics around our
children around the children in the in
Yoda Rock and about what you think some
of the repercussions are going to be not
just politically thank you
well my first reaction is I I think that
I think that John Kerry's yes vote is
particularly contemptible coming from
him and I think that John Kerry's vote
is a rebel is is a is a signal to us
about why we should not vote for him for
president just clearly his motivation
one reason I actually I spoke from
anti-war platforms with John Kerry in
California in 1966-67
and and he was when he came back from
Vietnam on stand as a Vietnam veteran
spoke out against the war he was one of
the most important early public voices
against the war who really got attention
I mean those of us who had been arguing
against the war for a much longer time
were unknowns and we couldn't get any
press coverage and it was a kind of
shocking situation in which it really
Helen was right that what really
happened was middle-class kids started
to die and that what soon as them as
soon as the middle class realized that
in in the United States that its own
that its own children were being
sacrificed in the war the anti-war
movement became a became a majority
movement but it wasn't up until then and
I mean I think Charles is point about
36% of the population already raising
questions about Iraq means that our
situation now is very different from our
situation then but it may well be that
the sources of our support are going to
come from ordinary folk not people like
John Kerry who are dreaming of becoming
president if I could just just say a
word worried about that I mean me what I
think I know something about is public
opinion and so I tried so I tried to
give maybe maybe a hopeful view of this
but if you want the non hopeful view I
think that a combination of what Helen
said earlier and what you suggested just
now is actually the unhelpful the
unhelpful scenario and one of the
reasons why it's important to be in
dissent now so one Road says that we
won't go to war for whatever reason
there are actually people arguing that a
cost
Quinn said the last couple of months
mean that in the end we won't go to war
but there is one scenario that says we
will eventually go to war and I'm not an
expert but you know folks I've talked to
have had who've been around the world
and lived in that part of the world have
convinced me that should we go to a real
war then we will in fact be in much
greater danger a much greater peril okay
from basically that part of the world
and you know taking it out on us one way
or the other
if that should happen then the real
danger is America's the Americans who
are dissenting and wondering right now
will flip in the same way as Helen was
noting before the Second World War that
you know the dissent or the questioning
about internationalism and intervention
went away with Pearl Harbor and so I
again it's the reason why if you oppose
the action you know the row we're going
on in Iraq you know now is the time to
dissent and now is the time to act
because should we go to war and should
the worst-case scenario play out the
folks middles or middle-class Americans
who right now are wondering will turn
and become loyal I mean and will become
loyal to whatever the policy exactly and
so so I mean it's not probably not not
what you wanted to hear and not a full
engagement with with the issue but it
does seem to me from what I know about
public opinion is that there is a real
perilous road that could be even worse
than it is now right and even without a
war in Iraq what Charles is describing
could happen anyway another attack on an
on an American institution is going to
have an effect like that Americans will
rally around so i we're obviously in
very precarious circumstances one
message i think everyone is saying
people both in the panelists and the
audience is that we're we're we suffer
from a lack of leadership in the country
that we're not we're not the leaders of
the country are not are not being
helpful at this terrible terrible moment
in our history this gentleman right here
please my name is Dana Donovan I'm a
visiting scholar here and I'd be
interested in hearing perhaps just as an
intellectual exercise which we love here
at MIT from any member of the panel do
you see anything redeeming so far in the
current presidency or any hope for
anything redeeming coming out of our
current president and I'm actually
asking that seriously well he has a
short attention span there's an election
in two years I think that he's so
hell-bent for war that it's very hard to
find the redeeming factor you know I
wished it was a bluff I pray I wanted to
be wrong on everything and I don't
understand why he can't see the
consequences why he doesn't think
there'll be more terrorism if we
actually we can win anything we've got
to know how we're the the king of the
mountain and and there's no question
that we're but we're also going to be
the bully of the Western world and do we
really want that reputation and for what
I mean we really respect people in this
world and they have their own way I'm
not saying I don't want democracy to
spread I do want it but not to our
warfare into bombs
yes please
hi my name is Erica Taylor and I'm a
broadcast journalism graduate student at
Boston University and my question is
directed to you miss Thomas in terms of
you say that the press rolls over in
place ed what advice do you have for
up-and-coming journalists in terms of
how we can maybe separate the press from
the government and cover things not so
much jaded by what public opinion is and
more so what we feel ethically speaking
the question is essentially how can
young journalists you tell them that you
pay them the taxpayer pays them and they
have to answer it they are public
servants if they don't like it that will
give up the job and you definitely you
can't be rude as I am but but you
definitely have to remind them they are
public servants and they are accountable
and they are supposed to answer
questions I mean if it's a deep dark
secret that would affect national
security no of course not I mean you
wouldn't want to jeopardize the lives of
troops during but every question is
legitimate
I believe practically if you didn't go
to public sources like politicians where
would you go apart from apart from the
traditional sources of information to
find out the truth how would a what
should a journal is do in that way
instead of just accepting what the
politicians tell well I say I think you
have to find the leak you have you have
to find some dissenter who doesn't mind
telling you the truth and who is so
upset
there aren't many deep throats around
but sometimes I think you have to find
out is everyone solid in that position
and if they're not you have to find out
what what is the break a lot in this
this president doesn't tolerate leaks
and he doesn't I mean he's got a solid
front and so forth and they were all
very much aware that they have to be on
board so it's very hard to find that
breaking point as there was in Bush one
even when you had
differences of opinion are even Reagan
when you had Jim Baker on one side and
Ed meals and the others and so it was a
real split but there'll always be
someone who's going to try to save the
country and you do need whistleblowers
that's true we've got to find them in a
way but they have to answer the
questions I mean they are accountable
and I think you have to remind them may
get the mad you may not get the answer
but you may put them on notice yes this
gentleman there yes right right there
yeah thank you my name is George McCray
I live in central square there's a very
interesting book that I've read this
year called defying Hitler by Sebastian
Hafner and I don't mean to imply that
the Bush administration are fascists
because they don't believe that they are
fascists or Nazis
I believe the corporatist which is
something different the book is
interesting because it's written was
written in 38 and put away and it's a
clear the clearest explanation I know of
how the process of the not suffocation
happened and reading that book was very
scary to me because many of the same
things seemed to be going on and when
you have senator byrd on the floor of
the senate quoting Goering as he did
when you have a high-ranking person in
the German government making a comment
about the similarities between some of
the tactics of the Bush administration
and the Nazi government and then being
fired for it things become very dicey
when you have the one person in the
Senate who voted against the war
suddenly dying in an airplane crash
there are many people whose noses are
twitching whose stomachs are a little
uneasy and I would hope that we find out
what really happened to that plane
because when you read the when you read
about that incident they're talking
about what's the political fallout but
they don't talk about what happened to
the plane and then you read another
article that says Mondale is asked
whether he's going to travel by plane
and he says no only by bus so I don't
mean to be impolite but I think that we
really have to examine the the
possibility that things are are much
darker than we think
I hope you're wrong and I don't believe
you're right bad as things are I think I
think I think these I think things are
terrible enough not to require
conspiracies there are enough there are
enough simple explanations for why
things are so terrible so that they
don't require that we imagine even worse
conspiracies yes I don't believe in
there is any conspiracy there has been a
chipping away of civil liberties no
doing fine but getting along they're
making great inroads into our rights and
so forth so they don't really have to
resort to anything as underhanded as
that horrible leave the notion that well
stones plane was shut down or were
always sabotage by by iraqi war mongers
or by bush but it makes no sense from
many angles one of the reasons would be
it's not as if well stone was the only
one who had spoken out against these
things nor is it a question of well
stone having any power so it's very hard
it's very hard to see the usefulness of
such a of such an account of the world
when um what a much more straightforward
account of the world is sufficient to
cause horrific nightmares
yes please my name is Elizabeth laws and
I'm an undergraduate here at MIT
studying economics and think you must
Thomas I enjoyed your presentation um I
see under President Bush's power
I do see a hopefulness and that's in
that he has the power to take us to war
and then he hasn't done it yet and his
professor Stewart said and I'm a fine
example of our public opinion is going
from a really scared very vulnerable
post September 11th
America looking for a football coach to
rally us and take us to war and now
we're starting to think about it and
we're starting to talk about it and
question whether this is really what we
need to do and I think we're asking for
more from him and of course the press is
helping and but I think we're looking
for a plan I'm also not anti-war I don't
think what we need is more of a grass
roots war is evil and unjust because of
course it is but we also have to be a
realist and think about America and what
what it stands for and why maybe we do
need to go to war one day and under
certain circumstances and I think what
we need to look for from him is a plan
that we can defend internationally and
ideologically and morally and openly one
that hopefully is a multilateral effect
and doesn't need to be done in the next
few years because Iraq won't have
nuclear weapons at least for a few years
but I'm curious as to what you think
about the possibility in the future of
having to go to war by necessity because
of the threat that a ruler like Saddam
Hussein who I think has vehement plans
against the United States and would like
to have a nuclear weapon to harm us and
also and more right now al Qaeda who
obviously would love to hurt us again
and what you think we should be doing
against them I mean we're basically a
war against Al Qaeda now and it's a hard
war to fight because
it's not a traditional one but I'm just
curious what you think about it on a
more finite terms as opposed to the
ideology of it well Saddam Hussein has
never threatened the United States he
may threaten Israel and Bey when in
terms of the whole question of the
Middle East but he's never threatened
the United States so you've gotta find a
reason to attack him and I don't think
you should find one I really don't think
that we should go looking for
provocation when there is none I mean
we're talking about human beings we're
talking about human lives is he going
balmy rocky why why I'm gonna kill
Americans why are you willing to give
your life I mean to mean to respond to
the question it strikes me that that
you've almost given me I think the
answer to your own question in your life
while you're talking about your life
story it strikes me I was out a Yale
Divinity School someone went to Harvard
Divinity School and was very much
influenced by the Vietnam years and
considered myself a pacifist for many
years I still do I think but the thing
that's really striking about the state
of September 11th attacks talking to my
friends who kind of grew up under the
same circumstances began to realize
there may really be conditions under
which we could support war and one of
those would be nations doing horrible
things to us very well beyond and so and
what's also striking kind of in public
opinion is that Americans have a lot of
Americans you used to be anti-war not
all but many beginning think well maybe
yes maybe no and there are some
traditions about thinking about that
Just War tradition and others and so it
strikes so it seems to me that one of
the reasons why it's it's really
interesting that so many Americans are
wondering about Iraq is that that wonder
and skepticism about Iraq comes at the
same time that there's kind of greater
willingness in general to find reasons
to retaliate by war
and so I mean I wouldn't want to speak
from his Thomas Thomas or for David but
but it strikes me that most of us
nowadays would say well you know if we
get attacked for for whatever reason and
one can you know blame the United States
for a lot in the world and quite
understand why it is the people would
want to hate us but you know don't do
horrible things to us or we may have in
fact who respond that's different from a
pre-emptive war which the which this
country and many of us are discovering
but we've never had a tradition of I
have one quick response I mean I think
that there was an answer to your
question and in the question as well
which is that we are already at war the
most shocking aspect of this business
about Iraq is the fact that it's not as
if the Bush administration has been so
brilliantly successful in its alleged
war on terrorism if we start looking at
it at its record in fact I think that
that I'm shocked that a democratic
politician isn't running against the
Bush administration for its incompetence
in protecting us in the war on terrorism
airports are still just as dangerous as
they ever were there's overwhelming
evidence that all that would that we
remain incredibly vulnerable to a single
sniper and yet we and yet we mean the
first single sniper paralyzed Washington
for three weeks and the and the FBI the
CIA and the police forces of Maryland
and Washington were incapable of
catching them immediately and this was
just to two individuals that I mean
there's I think there's overwhelming
evidence that the war on terrorism is a
serious business I don't think that the
Bush administration is taking it
seriously enough because if they were
they would not be talking about
extending to creating a second war
that's one response but but I have
something else to say I'm sorry to sound
so weirdly radical it's not like me but
the fact of the matter is if you put
yourself in the position of someone not
in the United States but living anyplace
else in the world and if you asked
someone living in France or someone
living in the Middle East or someone
living in Russia where which is the most
dangerous country in the world which
country in the world do you think is
most likely to start dropping bombs on
civilians do you think that the answer
would be Saddam Hussein or George Bush
the United States is right now the most
dangerous and the
law apparently potentially lawless
country in the world and where we really
need if we wanted to address our if we
wanted to address questions of people of
being being peaceful good neighbors we
would we would be much more aggressive
in attacking the immoral behavior of our
president right back there our last
question or comment yes right there
thank you okay thank you very much to
all thank you miss Thomas you've been a
role model in particular for me a
journalist from Europe my name is Nadia
christen and I go to school at the
Fletcher School my question is regarding
the international media when you and
your colleagues get together at
different press clubs or different
unions you have and you talk about the
way you report on whatever President
Bush plan is for for Iraq do you ask
your yourself and your colleagues how is
the European media for instance
reporting how's our just zero reporting
or other media outlets in in the Middle
East and if they do report different and
I think they do do you ask yourself why
you're not trying to report differently
if you have this frustration that the
media is basically aligned with the
president thank you
little negotiation around here it
happens do you worry about it do you
talk about it does it if you know what's
what you do I think we're very
interested in foreign coverage that's
for sure and we were very interested
when the national security affairs
advisor went to CNN another cable
outlets and told them not to use certain
things on al-jazeera
which is very underwater cause it's not
the way we do things I mean this is not
the way a Free Press operates you let it
all hang out you let the chips fall
where they may
that's where truth is so I'm certainly
aware that we are not liked in this
country anymore that our country is not
like where it was loved before everybody
who's traveled last summer came back
from Europe and so forth came back with
hair-raising tales about how how the new
Europeans were viewing us as not only
war mongers but not but lacking an
understanding yes we do care this is a
global village CMM can go anywhere in
five minutes
everybody's war is in your living room
it is one world and we certainly every
time anything happens anywhere I think
we are affected and certainly when you
cover the White House you get it all
from tricky track to everything that
happens in the world we are affected and
I think that we do worry and I think we
have to refurbish our image it's really
gone down badly
and I don't know if the White House is
really aware or really cares not when
you think of unilateralism and say who
in the hell cares you know we're we're
on top we can wipe out anyone weird this
but that's not the way the world works
and I'm afraid that they've bit off more
than they can chew if they don't care
what our image is Helen you're a delight
your subject isn't and you may not count
all that well but I know you count for
this audience and therefore you count
for MIT so I just on behalf of our
institution and the communications forum
I want to thank you and of course your
wonderful colleagues my friends for
putting on a wonderful show for us today
[Applause]